everybody Shawn McGinnis here from
gamespot news and your day just got 500
percent better because we're about to
talk Pokemon today during a special
broadcast the Pokemon company announced
pokken tournament a new fighting game
based on the popular series this is the
game that the company teased last week
saying it would represent a shocking
announcement so what do you think are
you shocked the development team at
Bandai Namco responsible for the Tekken
series is creating the new Pokemon
fighting game quote whether you are a
casual player a regular player or a
hardcore player anyone who likes Pokemon
can have fun veteran tekken producer
Katsuhiro Harada said during the event
as translated by Kotaku pokken
tournament will be released in 2015 for
Japanese arcades there's no word yet on
the possibility of a release for Western
markets or on consoles we'll continue to
update this story as new information
becomes available for more on fighting
games Pokemon or just fighting Pokemon
make sure to come back to GameSpot calm